foreign
[Music]
I am Richard Ebert from the University
of Minnesota for the past 12 years I
have been associated with a Veterans
Administration Cooperative study on the
use of anticoagulants the treatment of
myocardial infarction
my position today is that anticoagulants
are indicated in certain selected cases
of acute myocardial infarction
my name is Dean Mason
I'm from the section of cardiopulmonary
medicine at the University of California
new school of medicine at Davis
California
my position today is that while I am not
against the use of anticoagulants in the
treatment of patients with coronary
arterial disease I have not been
enthusiastic about their routine
employment in these patients
I am Arthur Selter of the Pacific
Medical Center in San Francisco as the
moderator of this presentation I'll try
to focus on the important issue to
present both sides of the controversy
hahahaha
welcome to the exploration of Concepts
and controversies in modern medicine one
of a series of programs dedicated to
examining the uncertain candidly
recognizing that much of today's
teaching is necessarily based upon
opinion and that the opinions of eminent
physicians in a given field vary widely
the national medical audio visual Center
believes that openly airing such
opposing views is a basic responsibility
of medical Communications
Dr Arthur selser director of
cardiopulmonary laboratory at the
Pacific Medical Center will act as
moderator of this presentation
the subject for today's discussion is
anticoagulation
in the treatment of myocardial
infarction this subject can be
subdivided into two sections the
treatment of the acute states of
myocardial infarction and The Chronic
anticoagulant therapy for patients who
have survived the acute attack the
objective in the acute myocardial
infarction is the prevention of the
specific complications that develop in
myocardial infarction primarily
intramural
thrombi with systemic embolization and
peripheral thrombi was pulmonary
embolization
The Chronic stage has entirely different
objectives since recurrence myocardial
infarction is to a large extent caused
by a intra-coronary arterial thrombi
forming a coronite thrombosis
anticoagulant treatment sets as its
objective the prevention of recurrent
myocardium infarction
the objectives of this of this treatment
is very well taken however the
controversy is based on two points one
is are we sure that the anticoagulant
treatment actually can fulfill this
objective and the second is the risk of
this therapy justifiable one can
furthermore bring out the point that
this is preventive therapy not treatment
of existing disease but prevention of
future complication and one could
perhaps take the standpoint that
preventive treatment needs an even
firmer
justification in terms of risk than
actual therapy of disease I will now
introduce Dr Richard Ebert
who will take the positive stance on
this issue
one of the problems in the question of
the treatment of patients with acute
myocardial infarction with
anticoagulants is the polarization of
opinion which occurs
individuals tend to stay take very
strong stands on one side or another let
us briefly look at the evidence on which
these opinions are based
there have been several large-scale
studies of the use of anticoagulants and
the treatment of acute myocardial
infarction
the recent Studies have not shown a
difference in mortality between the
treated and the untreated group
this in no way proves that there may not
be a small difference but this
difference is not easily demonstrable
on the other hand there is clear-cut
evidence that therapy does reduce the
incidence of thromboembolic phenomena in
acute myocardial infarction
we are speaking now both of pulmonary
and Malai and systemic mli the last are
particularly important because of the
devastating effect of these emboli
for this reason it is my opinion that in
certain selected incidents instances of
acute myocardial infarction
where there is a high incidence of
thrombolic complications that
anticoagulants may be used for their
prophylactic effect
the situation in the instance of
long-term use of anticoagulants
following acute myocardial infarction is
even more complex
let us look at the study done by the
Veterans Administration Cooperative
group
this study was carried on for over five
years and involved approximately 740
patients
you will note that the survival of the
treated group is better than the
survival of the untreated group of two
years
this difference is statistically
significant however when we follow these
patients out to five years we find no
difference in the survival between the
treated and untreated group
thus there is evidence that during the
first two years following acute
myocardial infarction anticoagulants do
produce a modest reduction in mortality
this is confirmed by a number of other
studies which have been done in various
countries throughout the world
Dean Mason will now present the opposing
standpoint automation
I think that it's important to point out
at the beginning that there appears to
be a fundamental difference between the
Genesis of arterial thrombi and Venus
thrombi
it's now clear I think that
platelet deposition Begins the formation
of arterial thrombi and the Venus
thrombi or more are more related to
fibrin clots
thus perhaps there is at least a
fundamental reason
not to to have great expectations for
anticoagulants to reduce
the formation of arterial thrombi
now when one looks at the use of
anticoagulants in
acute myocardial infarction
I certainly would agree that
the studies overall have not shown that
have not shown a decrease in mortality
rate between treated and untreated
patients I think initially there was
great hope that perhaps mortality wasn't
diminished
by the use of anticoagulants but more
recently some large studies a Danish
study and perhaps also a recent British
study have shown that mortality rate has
not been reduced so results are
conflicting and somewhat confusing in
regards to mortality rate in acute
myocardial infarction I think it's also
clear and I would agree that all of the
studies have generally shown a decrease
in thromboembolic phenomena of both
Venus and systemic embolic phenomenon
and this is important
uh in interpreting these facts
for the treatment of patients in my
opinion I have not routinely used
anticoagulants in patients with acute
myocardial infarction but have reserved
them for those patients
who require bed rest for a number of
days
it's been our practice in patients with
so-called good risk patients who have no
evidence of heart failure or problems
with arrhythmia or hypotension to get
them up relatively early
this is opposed to the traditional view
that several days of bed rest are
required and bed rest is terminated
after the second or third day and then
they're gotten up to a chair arrest
I feel that this maneuver
takes the place of the routine use of
anticoagulants
to prevent both Venus and the systemic
thromboembolic phenomena
I would emphasize again though that I
would use anticoagulants in so-called
bad risk patients who will require bed
rest for several days he's being
patients with heart failure and
arrhythmias uh generally now when one
turns to um the use of anticoagulants in
patients The Chronic use of
anticoagulants in patients to prevent uh
perhaps the recurrence of myocardial
infarction and reduce mortality rate
prophylactically
I think perhaps there's more controversy
in this area
it's clear that with this particular use
of the anticoagulant of
thromboembolic complications are not the
not the target for therapy but we're
attempting to reduce the extension and
new formation of arterial thrombi
I think that when one looks at all of
the studies that had been done
the overall view is that in certain
selected patients
there is a borderline perhaps of
significance in the reduction of
recurrence of myocardial infarction in
certain age groups particularly those
less than 60 or 55 years of age
um
there have been perhaps more studies on
the positive side of The Ledger than on
the negative side the Veterans
Administration study that Dr Ebert has
been associated with is is perhaps the
champion study showing the benefits of
reducing uh
mortality rate and preventing recurrence
of myocardial infarction there have been
studies though that have not shown this
and this I think has led to confusion in
terms of the overall View
my interpretation of these findings has
been not to routinely use anticoagulants
in patients who have had myocardial
infarction for prophylactic therapy
because I think it's not yet clear
whether there is any benefit derived and
if there is benefit derived it appears
to be relatively marginal to a selected
group of patients for a short period of
time
I think that um
in my opinion it's unlikely that
anticoagulants really alter the
fundamental process or processes
underlying myocardial infarction I think
that there are a number of other factors
that perhaps are more important and thus
I would Place emphasis on
these other factors and perhaps also on
new approaches to therapy
I think that the one thing appears to be
quite clear from both presentation that
there is no good evidence at the present
time that we are that we have
demonstrated reduced mortality in the
acute state of myocardial infarction so
I think that perhaps I can interpret
what the speakers Say by indicating that
there is a
reduction of thrombin body complication
non-fatal complications so I like to ask
Dr Ebert whether he feels that this is a
justifiable end for the routine use in
every patient and has marked in Parks I
would like to comment about the
mortality this is not the place to go
into the mathematics of probability and
I'm not capable of doing so but it it
should be recognized that with studies
of a thousand or so patients that one
cannot preclude there being a difference
of two or three percent event in the
mortality between the two groups I just
wish to bring that out but it's not a
cure-all that's obvious now as far as
the use of adequatically it's a
concerned I'm afraid that Dr Mason and I
are in Brave danger of taking the same
stand and I'm afraid that that would do
considerable damage to the program but I
too feel that the antichrists acute
myocardial infarction should be
administered to those individuals who
are so-called high-risk patients this
was suggested by russic back around 1950
and I'm afraid his Viewpoint is coming
back again not afraid of it but it looks
as though his Viewpoint is correct I
think there's very little evidence that
in those individuals with mild
infarctions perhaps a non-transmural
where there are no complications whether
up early I don't think there's very much
evidence in favor of using anticoagans
well do you have any comments Dr Mason
I'm pleased to see that we are in
agreement
um
I get I get the feeling that this is
getting to be the overall view of a
number of people uh
[Music]
maybe I can speak with considerable
Authority from the subject that I've had
last year in myocardial infarction and
elected not to use anticoagulants
I hope a good risk
I think that perhaps we should therefore
as in as much this phase of it seems to
be an agreement and I perhaps should
mention that there are still many areas
and some people who Advocate the routine
use even in mildest possible case of
anticoagans and I'm very glad to know
that there is agreement in this point
that it may not be really warranted with
the evidence as it has presented itself
now one point I'd like to make and that
is that further studies are necessary to
Define that group in which Antiquated
should be used we don't have enough
knowledge now about the prediction from
webolar complications I think that the
question of chronic anticoagulant
represents an entirely different area
because here you take a relatively well
person who commits himself for the rest
of his life or perhaps for a certain
number of years to take on
anticoagulation which carries a certain
amount of risk and which you may
interfere with many other diseases that
may develop and the evidence as was
pointed out by Dr Mason is a
controversial in the sense that benefits
are not as clearly
indicated as one would want to to know
to convince everybody
I would like to perhaps ask a question
by pointing out to some of the criticism
which was centered on the whole problem
by Sir John McMichael of England and he
has particularly
shown a graph
that indicates
that
taking all the known statistics on the
treatment of the
survival five-year survival after my
Academy infarction from every source and
that goes into thousands of cases in the
pre-anticoagulant area he has tried to
fit the the
[Music]
cases of various series into this area
and as you may see on the graph
it shows that all the control studies
are outside the area of
of the is known survival ratio as if it
were that patients who are controller do
worse than the average and the positive
treatment is merely bringing it up to
the average now I have looked through
your data in your study also falls below
this line as shown here would you have
any comments on well I think that uh
but Michael's comments were extremely
pertinent at the time and very healthy
however they were not specifically
directed to the modern type of study
that uses randomization
uh what accepts the fact that in a
large-scale study what is dealing with a
selected group of patients to begin with
in our case we were dealing with
veterans but with proper randomization
techniques the true group should be
comparable and therefore the mortality
can be compared in a valid manner now
the problem comes at applying this to
the population as a whole to the
universe but the conclusions regarding
the specific population can still be
valid that's Mason you have any comments
on this idea that controls in the
various studies do worse than the
non-average is in terms of survival this
is an interesting phenomenon because
it's as if the patient's uh do worse
when somebody else someone else gets the
anticoagulant
um
I would agree uh with what Dr Ebert says
I think that uh
well controlled and well randomized
studies are the most useful types of
studies and that
uh what's been confusing about that is
that even these sorts of studies
themselves have been confused
perhaps I should ask you to comment on
the study of the University of Oregon
group who's Dr Seaman and Dr Griswold
who have done a small group but what
they feel and extremely well controlled
study showing that there is no
difference in survival would you like to
say a few words about it well this was
an impressively controlled study that Dr
Selzer refers to that was recently
reported
um
it examines a
three groups of patients one receiving
anticoagulants Another one not receiving
anticoagulants but done in a
double-blind fashion so that neither the
physician or the patient knew whether he
was getting anticoagulants and then
there was a third known control group
and it was of interest that these
investigators did not find any benefit
from prophylactic anticoagulation in
regards to mortality rate or recurrence
of myocardial infarction or in any other
area
um
this is of interest when when this is
compared to the very very well done
study carried out by the Veterans
Administration which employed a great
deal more patience and therefore the
evaluation for significance was was
perhaps uh more meaningful
I think that these two studies represent
the two good studies that we now have on
either side of the fence
would you like to comment as you know
the Portland group feels that a small
well-controlled group of patients
perhaps represent a better population
and the larger where you cannot have the
same type of control it should not be
forgotten that the overall conclusions
of the Portland group did not really
differ from ours if you remember the
Veterans Administration study the
overall mortality for the whole study
was no different in the anticoagulant
treated group and those not treated they
found the same thing now we demonstrated
a difference at two years which did not
persist until five years and in their
recent article they pointed out that
their numbers were not large enough to
demonstrate that difference if it did
exist assume it didn't existed they
still couldn't have understood
there's one thing in your study that
puzzled me and that is that as in your
graph that was shown earlier you've
shown that they separate but they come
together at the end say four or five
years
that would logically mean that after a
certain time patients who are on therapy
do worse than the controls that's right
during the third fourth and fifth year
they uh they control the treated group
are dying at a greater rate than the
control group now you have to remember
that the adequators are not necessarily
killing them this could simply represent
delayed death of individuals in the
treated group you find the same kind of
things if you look at cancer
chemotherapy statistics that perhaps the
controls die early and the others die a
little bit later but they all die
perhaps naively one can think that if
you stop after two years then then
they'll still do better well this is
what what might conclude and hopefully
conclude is not necessarily valid of
course
and do you and you have any other
information that you would like to put
through in trying to focus only do you
have any knowledge of the the negative
side in terms of complications and how
after all you have to pay a price for
taking on the coagulants people are
involved in accidents people have
gastrointestinal disease with bleeding
has has an impressed very much that the
price may be too high I think this is of
concern Dr Selzer I think that we always
have to be concerned when we
prophylactically use the type of therapy
which has a tendon to its use a certain
Hazard and very clearly the use of
anticoagulants does carry that hazard
um and I have really used this
particular
concern to uh
allow myself to feel that this concern
balances or perhaps outweighs the
possible beneficial effects of
prophylactic
anticoagulation and therefore I've not
used them routinely
uh in our study there was approximately
a one percent mortality from Hemorrhage
of course there were a fairly large
number of hemorrhages but they're one
percent mortality
well I think I personally am convinced
that I elected not to use the chronic
regulation so I think my stance is
exemplified by by this point
we have and we have had some experience
with some of the series where the
control of anticoagulation was
inadequate in other words
it is to be effective you have to really
have the situation under control to have
you encountered any difficulty in
controlling these patients well we
ultimately developed a fairly
sophisticated group
most of the investigators remain in the
study for five or ten years
we had Central laboratory control of our
reagents and as a result I think the
control of the level of the coagulation
factors was quite good I should
emphasize that this is not necessarily
true in the instance of uh individuals
practicing in various parts of the
country or one problem is that the
reagents are not well standardized in
the United States
you have any any advice that you may
give the physician in a small community
in terms of in his particular situation
you think it's more difficult to control
than I think in general it is I think
that the each physician has to examine
the facts and make these decisions for
himself I think it's interesting to make
one other point that I think it's now
clear that many patients who have
myocardial infarction do not appear to
have a
coronary thrombosis so if
we're preventing coronary thrombosis
it's obvious that in certain instances
the myocardial infarction is is due due
to other factors
the situation I think fundamentally is
complex
certainly the feeling that prevailed
some years ago that this is an
obligation of a physician to use it
routinely to extend life is probably not
warranted by any of the study would you
agree I'd agree with that
oh
yeah I think that in in terms of
there
and the use of anticoagulants it has at
times even become a question of whether
illegal liability would like comment on
it since the pressure has been so high
on some positions it's my impression
that the evidence is such that
the physician has no right to make the
decision in any given case I don't think
there's any question of legal liability
whatsoever have you been under pressure
from patients who've who want to have it
done because they've read that this is
such a good treatment does it happen to
you in your own not not often and
generally when all of the facts Pro and
Conor are presented to them this no
longer exists
or have you any any comments on the
general population and sort of the
educational process how all the
anticoagulant I mean in terms of the
public as a whole thing as a whole well
I the problem is so complex that I don't
feel strongly that the public should be
informed in depth in this area but they
are whether we want it or not
I think that in summarizing this panel
it is quite clear that perhaps the
controversy is not as as broad as one
might imagine I think the agreement has
been among the two speakers that in
acute myocardial infarction the acute
States mortality in the acute stage is
not influenced but the prevention of
serious complications could be averted
and that would justify the use of
anticoagulants and patients who are the
most likely the most likely to have
these complications what is often
referred to as the poorest patient
on the other hand on The Chronic stage
the claims are not very sweeping to the
fact that the life expectancy of
patients who recover from cardio
infarction is prolonged but rather that
in certain group of patients there is a
slight difference between
between the treated and untreated
patients and even the slight difference
amongst some groups cannot be
demonstrated thank you very much
we thank Dr Richard B Ebert Dr Dean T
Mason and Dr Arthur selser for their
interesting analysis of a critical
problem in patient care
in subsequent programs we shall continue
to record equally significant Concepts
and controversies in modern medicine
the opinions expressed on this program
do not necessarily constitute
endorsement by the department of health
education and Welfare the Public Health
Service for its constituents
[Music]
beautiful